Build it.
Draw it.
Play It.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it
Estonian Designer Pavel Sidorenko repurposes
old vinyl records into wall clocks.
The series is called Re-Vinyl and he wants
to reduce the waste of useful materials as
well decrease the consumption of new materials.
Some of his designs include cityscapes, animals,
human interaction, and inanimate objects.
Alvaro Cassinelli created these robotic Japanese
garden lamps for an exhibition in Tokyo.
They're able to sense other objects so they
don't step on plants or run into anything
in the garden and they can be controlled with
a smart device.
His hope is to one day have a garden that
takes care of itself in the absence of humans.
Designer Echo Yang made these autonomous drawing
machines out of everyday objects paired with
different media.
Including a hand mixer using water color,
a wind up clock using pencil lead, and a Walkman
using charcoal.
Dustin Yellin makes 3D collages by encasing
objects into layers of glass.
He uses pieces he finds on the street, clippings,
computer generated images, acrylic, and glass
to create the sculptures.
Like this massive piece that weighs 12 tons
and is 46.5 inches tall, 69 inches long, and
27 inches deep and his latest series is called
psychogeographies.
Draw it
High Voltage is a project by Phillip David
Stearns that merges electronics with photography.
He produces images by applying 15,000 volts
of electricity to instant color film, that's
about 1,000 times the strength of a car battery.
It creates an organic pattern and shows off
the ability of instant film beyond its typical
use of capturing the world around us.
Grand Pale Maw is a giant mural using only
latex paint and a black sharpie.
It took artist Sean Sullivan seven months
to get to the point where he finally considered
it done, partly because he exceeded his original
timeline by four months.
Now for When the Lights Go Out 2, an art showcase
featuring glow in the dark prints.
A'shop is a production company that creates
giant scale graffiti murals, street art, and
urban aesthetics.
They have a large collection of artists that
work for both commercial and private clients
to make murals for interiors and exteriors
as well as custom art pieces.
Find the link below to check out the full
video.
Play it
Classic Pianist Yoshiki performed a piano
duel with a hologram of himself live at the
2014 South By Southwest.
Reading my body created by Dmitry Morozov
is a sound controller that detects ink on
your skin to play your tattoos.
The Georgia Tech Center for Music Technology
created this robotic drumming prosthesis used
here by Jason Barnes.
Finally Cell Song by Fanfarlo is a music video
created by Ewan Jones Morris using old science
journals and eyclopedias.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube or share them with everyone
over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out YOUR BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to only your creations.
And as always - thanks for watching.